California became the nation's first
sanctuary state in January the law
prohibits police from cooperating with
or detaining criminal aliens for ice
with thousands living in close proximity
on Skid Row hygiene is always an issue
but with an official outbreak of
hepatitis A it's now a necessity just
before midnight on March 3rd Anderson
was driving his semi truck on i-70 when
police say he was hit and killed the man
charged with Anderson's death is ivan is
emma Reba Castaneda he's an undocumented
immigrant out on bond wanted by ice the
golden state has lost its glow obviously
California now has more poverty than any
state homelessness is completely out of
control state officials are still
focused on protecting illegal immigrants
from deportation rather than any of the
problems the state faces including the
flood of its entire middle class it's a
sad picture one man who sees it clearly
as soon as been there a long time actor
model Fabio he's the immigrant to the
state but not one of those state
officials care about Fabio joins us
tonight
so Bobby thanks for coming on I want to
read I don't live there anymore but I
read about California everyday here are
two headlines tell me if they sum up
what it's like now this is just from the
other day Orange County homeless camp
clean up 400 tons of debris fourteen
thousand needles five thousand pounds of
human waste
here's the second California lowers the
penalty for knowingly exposing someone
to HIV it sounds chaotic and dirty is
that your experience yeah well let me
tell you something right now about
California it look like a wild wild west
you don't look farther than the leaders
of California Jerry Brown Libby the
mayor of Oakland you know Jerry Brown
with proposition 47 57 bill 109 is to
totally decide of the criminals is when
on a criminal side totally turned his
back on a law enforcement and you know
the leaders of California they acting
criminals they acting like criminals so
will you expect the rest of the people
going to do then you have the mayor of
Oakland who Tolly tell all the criminal
to run away because ice is coming over
so instead to do overnight Android the
arrest they only arrest about I think
hundred and twenty hundred and thirty
people then you have you know the the
omelets the homeless if you look if you
go downtown Los Angeles Tucker it's like
it's like I've been around the world
I remember being thirty years ago in
Africa Africa doesn't look like that in
in in it's unbelievable no either third
world country thirty years ago ago look
like California right now like downtown
you know you go down to the like the
library it's like Sodom and Gomorrah I
mean it's like sex sex drugs and rock
and roll it's it's a library no it's
it's in the library I mean you should do
at all segments on the library a public
library downtown Los Angeles and I'm
telling you it's unbelievable it's like
Sodom and Gomorrah only Californian
librarians have put up with that - what
what year did you get to California when
did you move there about in 92 92 so now
you know I yes now second force because
because I live in in Washington because
I'm telling you it's like the California
leaders they totally destroyed the
middle class in California yes you know
the majority of the California's broke
and you have a few wealthy people about
5700 people pay almost 40% 37 percent
exactly of the entire California income
tax is brought on let me tell you it's
unbelievable company every single
company is running away because of tax
reason and including the movie industry
of course they are every single movie
outside of California are gonna be there
soon we're bringing the show to
California and we will see you then
favia thank you hang in there
thank you so much